une journée particulière aux états unis
journée de commémoration des attentats
du 11 septembre c'était il ya six mois
jour pour jour
à cette occasion la télévision
américaine cbs a diffusé un film inédit
un film réalisé par deux jeunes français
deux frères venus tourner un
documentaire sur les pompiers de new
york et qui ont donc vécu ce jour-là à
leurs côtés ses deux frères c'est vous
jules et gédéon naudet vous nous en
parlerait dans un instant précisément
cet affront pied de new york qui est
assis entre vous deux un film
impressionnant et qui a évidemment ému
les américains ils étaient 39 millions
devant leur poste hier soir c'est un
record
nous allons d'abord en découvrir un
extrait un très large extrait
commentaires pascal golomer notre
correspondant à new york
il devait s'agir à l'origine d'un
documentaire sur l'apprentissage d'un
jeune pompier à manhattan plusieurs
semaines de tournage dans une caserne
ce n'est pas de la rigolade ce boulot où
il faut penser à plein de choses
restez toujours concentré c'est ce qui
te permettra de rester en vie et de
sauver d'autres jeunes nous sommes le 11
septembre
les pompiers sont appelés pour une
simple fuite de gaz dans la rate un
contrôle de routine
il est 8 heures 46
et
[Applaudissements]
dès le début j'ai compris que ce serait
la pire journée de ma carrière de
banquier j'ai su tout de suite que ce
n'était pas un accident
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes garés à l'entrée de la tour
numéro un
le chef fight for en vue je lui demande
si je peux venir avec vous comme ils me
répondent oui mais tu restes avec moi je
viens avec moi tu ne me quitte pas
j'entre et j'entends des cris à droite
il y a deux grands fous je n'ai pas
voulu filmer
je me suis dit personne ne doit voir
cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
piper est le premier chef à l'intérieur
de l'immeuble
il organise les secours
[Applaudissements]
les pompiers arrivent calmement qu'il
s'apprête à monter dans les étages avec
leurs trente kilos d'équipement sur le
dos beaucoup ne sortiront pas vivants du
wall trade center
lemonnier mychal judge est de ceux là
c'était la première fois que je voyais
le père john avant je voyais qu'il était
en train de prier
deux avions le premier sur la tour
numéro 1 et l'autre vient de s'écraser
sur la deuxième tour tout le monde
regardait la même chose parler de la
même chose
ils réagissaient de la même façon on l'a
vu on l'a vu un avion qu'est ce que les
gens vont faire les ascenseurs sont
bloqués peut-être les escaliers alors
les minutes passent les occupants de la
tour numéro un
puis comme une peur
[Applaudissements]
il est 10 heures 5 un bruit
assourdissant personne parmi les
pompiers ne comprend ce qui se passe
c'est la tour numéro de qui ces fonds
[Applaudissements]
et alors j'ai réagi je me suis dit je ne
suis pas mort j'allume le projecteur sur
ma caméra
[Musique]
il y avait des débris partout dans le
sol était jonché de poussière on regarde
dessus de nous et on voit la tour numéro
un on se dit tout va bien la tour est
toujours debout et la tour numéro deux
doit être caché derrière personne ne
nous avait rien dit
et puis quelques secondes plus tard
je sens alors quelqu'un se jeter sur moi
et puis la poussière
[Applaudissements]
il est 13 heures les deux frères se
retrouvent vivant l'un et l'autre plus
rien ne sera pour eux comme avant voilà